I didn't understand divorce I will say
that I probably should have fell back
Jada Pinkett Smith's kicked off the
first episode of her Facebook watch
series read Table Talk on Monday with
one potentially awkward conversation I
called back and I happen to say quote
you living in a house I picked out you
said it's my house now
that's a 46 year old and her husband
Will Smith's first wife Sheree xanpe
know it's the first time Sheree and I
actually have sat down to talk about it
and it was and it's so important because
we talk about it and we talk about our
journey and we've come so far with
Sheree and I've been doing this for tres
25 we've been doing it for 23 years and
I was like we could help a lot of people
and just how is starting how rough it
was and along the way we'll and Sheree
married in 1992 divorced in 1995 and
share a 25 year-old son Trey together
the two got candid about the rough start
to their relationship when Jada and will
married in 1997 so when I think back
about where I was some of my
insensitivity some my in consideration
just in regards to you guys unwinding a
marriage yeah and then me trying to get
in there and like bless her little heart
both women got emotional when Sheree
admitted it was tough when will first
introduced trade to Jada so tre comes
home I said how did you like Miss Jada
he said I really liked her
thank you for loving my baby and shuri
praise Jada for building a relationship
with her son on this side of things
right my son could not have a better
poet smile thank you Ray
no thank you he couldn't and he's got a
great mother
thank you
[Music]